>> Sean: CEASE AND DESIST?
THE IDEA CAME FROM ME.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW STUPID
SOME OF YOU PEOPLE ARE THAT
SUPPOSEDLY WORK IN THE
BUSINESS.
JOINING US NOW AUTHOR OF THE
NEW BOOK "LIARS, LEAKERS AND
LIBERALS.
THE CASE AGAINST THE
ANTI-TRUMP CONSPIRACY."
JUDGE PIRRO IN THE HOUSE.
ALSO WITH US THE NUMBER ONE
HOST ON THE FOX BUSINESS
NETWORK, GOOD FRIEND LOU DOBBS
WITH US.
OKAY.
I SAD BAD IDEA, THIS WON'T
WORK OUT WELL FOR YOU.
THEY ARE MORE MAD -- HOW DID
THEY NOT GET IT?
>> THEY DON'T GET IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE SO CONSUMED WITH THE
TRUMP ARRANGEMENT SYNDROME IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHO DOES RIGHT
OR WRONG.
IF YOU SAY ANYTHING THEY WILL
HATE YOU FOR IT.
WHEREAS ONE SAID, I WROTE IT
DOWN, WHERE DID THE IDEA COME
FROM?
>> Sean: FROM ME.
>> NO.
THE IDEA CAME FROM HILLARY
CLINTON.
IT WAS A JOKE ON WHAT HILLARY
CLINTON DID.
C'MON!
>> Sean: SHE DID THESE
THINGS.
>> SHE GOT A WARNING -- LOOK,
YOU BETTER --
>> Sean: A WARNING?
SHE BROKE THE LAW.
>> LEAK E-MAIL AND DESTROY THE
EVIDENCE IN CASE WE COME FOR
YOU BUT WE'RE NOT COMING FROM
YOU.
>> FOR THE FOLKS TO TAKE YOU
SERIOUSLY SUGGESTS ONE
THING --
>> Sean: THAT SOUNDS BAD.
THAT MOMENT WAS SARCASTIC AS
HELL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT I HEARD
YOU LIVE.
IT WAS A FUNNY BIT.
I WAS TERRIFIC.
BUT FOR THOSE FOLKS TO TRY TO
PRETEND IN FRONT OF THEIR
AUDIENCES WHO COME TO THEM FOR
A SEMBLANCE ON PERSPECTIVE ON
THE WORLD AND TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY -- LET ME EXPLAINS
WHAMMED HERE.
I DON'T KNOW A NAME OF THE
SINGLE PERSON YOU PUT IN FRONT
OF US IN THE AUDIENCE.
>> Sean: I DON'T EITHER.
>> I'LL BET THAT THE MSNBC
AUDIENCE DOESN'T KNOW THE NAME
OF THOSE FOLKS.
THE REASON THEY ARE MENTIONED
THE NAME AND ANY CONTEXT AT
ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO AFFIX
THEMSELVES TO SOME PART OF
THE --
>> Sean: WAIT.
>> -- STATUS.
>> Sean: HOW DID I BECOME
CLICK BAIT?
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> THE WHOLE IDEA TO SAY WOMEN
WHO SUPPORT TRUMP ARE NUMB OR
DEAD INSIDE.
HOW DARE YOU CRASH THE WOMEN
OF THIS COUNTRY AS DEAD INSIDE
BECAUSE WE DON'T AGREE WITH
YOU.
>> Sean: ANYBODY WATCHING
KNOWS THAT'S FALSE.
YOU ARE VERY ALIVE.
WHAT A HISTORIC WEEK WE ARE
HEADING INTO.
>> YOU BET.
>> THERE IS NO RISK TO THE
PRESIDENT HERE.
HE MANAGED THE EXPECTATIONS.
MAYBE IT NEEDS FIVE MEETINGS
OR MAYBE WE END THE KOREAN
WAR.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS
COMMUNICATED THIS WEEK IN HIS
BODY LANGUAGE AND HIS WORDS
AND HIS ACTIONS JUST HOW ON
TAXPAYER OF HIS GAME HE IS.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT NOT ONLY
HAD THE MOST HISTORIC LIST OF
ACHIEVEMENTS OF ANY PRESIDENT
SINCE FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT IN A
YEAR AND A HALF BUT HE HAS
GROWN IMMENSELY AS A LEADER.
THIS IS A MAN WHO IS A NATURAL
BORN LEADER.
HE HAS LED BUSINESS.
HE HAS LED NOW THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: I THINK HE HAS
FIGURED IT OUT.
>> THIS MAN FOUND HIS VOICE.
HE KNOWS, HE HAS KNOWN WHO HE
IS THROUGHOUT.
AND NOW HE KNOWS THE JOB.
THAT MEANS IF YOU ARE RYAN,
McCONNELL, SCHUMER, PELOSI,
RUN FOR COVER BECAUSE HE IS
GOING TO HAVE HIS WAY.
MARK MY WORDS.
>> Sean: IT'S SAD THAT THE
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS THEIR BEST
OPPORTUNITY.
ALL THEY HAVE TO SAY THIS IS A
GREAT AGENDA.
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY AND
FOREIGN POLICY.
EVERYTHING IS GETTING BETTER.
THEY SHOULD BE HAPPY AND WANT
TO BE PART OF IT.
>> PAUL RYAN CAN'T STAND THE
FACT THAT HE DOESN'T AMOUNT TO
SHOE LACES ON THE
PRESIDENT'S --
>> Sean: YOU SCARED ME
THERE.
SHHH-SHOE LACES.
>> I'M USED TO GOING OTHER
PLACES.
>> Sean: I HEARD IT, LOU.
LET ME ASK YOU, NOT ONLY THE
NORTH KOREAN SUMMIT.
NOW WE HAVE AN I.G. REPORT.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
TIMING OF THE RELEASE.
18 MONTHS AND WE ARE GOING TO
RELEASE IT TWO DAYS AFTER THE
SUMMIT.
THE LEAKS I HEAR.
INSUBORDINATE WITH JAMES
COMEY.
ARE THEY GOING TO TELL US THE
TRUTH?
HILLARY BROKE THE LAW.
HILLARY COMMITTED FELONIES AND
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
AND COMEY AND OTHERS PUT THE
FIX IN AND WROTE THE
EXONERATION MONTHS BEFORE THEY
DID THE INVESTIGATION.
>> HERE IS THE TRUTH.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS NO
POWER.
IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH YOU WANT
TO SAY THANKS FOR THE REPORT.
BUT WHERE IS THE BEEF?
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE POWER TO
INDICT.
SHOULD JAMES COMEY BE
INDICTED?
THE QUESTION BASED ON WHAT I
HAVE HEARD IS YES.
>> Sean: McCAIN GOT A
CRIMINAL REFERRAL AFTER THE
I.G. REPORT.
WE'LL DO THIS WITH SARAH AND
GREGG NEXT.
>> COMEY, THEY HAVE TO.
>> Sean: I THINK COMEY,
STROZK, McCABE ALL IN DEEP
TROUBLE.
>> WILL THEY TURN AGAINST
SOMEONE HIGHER?
>> Sean: THEY HAVE.
THEY ARE BUILDING A PROFFER
WITH McCABE NOW.
>> HIGHER.
>> Sean: WELL, THAT WAS THE
LATEST STROZK/PAGE TEXT SAID
IT'S BEING DIRECTED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW AND WHEN
>> THAT'S MY POINT.
IF YOU WANT IMMUNITY, HIT
THE --
>> Sean: FOR SOMEONE WHO IS